[Musique]
ce vendredi 1er avril s'est déroulée la
signature d'un nouveau pacte de
solidarité territoriale pour la commune
des avirons entre le président du
département cyrille melchior et le maire
éric ferrères un budget de deux millions
six cent mille euros alloués dans le
cadre de ce pst deuxième génération le
parc de solidarité territoriale bas ce
sont des financements que le département
apporte aux communes et les avirons bien
évidemment dispose de ces financements
poids tout ce que la mairie décide de
fait sur son territoire que ce soit pour
les écoles les chemins communaux les
équipements sportifs de loisirs des
équipements culturels et bien tout cela
bénéficie de financements du département
près de deux millions cinq cent mille
euros et je suis fier de venir parce que
des fois on nous dit qu il faut pas
rester dans le bureau il fallait voir en
ce qui se passe sur le terrain eh bien
je viens quand comment la mairie des
avirons utilise donc les financements du
département une des actions phare de la
commune financé à hauteur de 72 mille
euros par le pst 2 l'épicerie sociale et
solidaire baptisé maison mère jane est
alors l'organisation fait ici au niveau
de l'épicerie sociale ont bénéficié à la
fois des produits de ramasse les
produits dram as en fait c'est tout ce
qui est tout ce qui reste des invendus
lutter contre l' le gaspillage
alimentaire donc par le biais de deux
enseignes
supermarché avec qui on travaille
régulièrement donc qui nous alimente
trois fois par semaine et ensuite au
niveau de l'épicerie c'est aussi des
achats pour pouvoir compléter que le ccs
fait par rapport aux besoins des
familles donc ça peut être à la fois
sûre du frais sur du sec mais aussi sur
les produits légumes et fruits donc en
fonction de ce qu'elles ont besoin la
visite s'est poursuivie au collège des
avirons avec une rencontre des élèves
des parents et
le collège des avirons et comme une
maison créole c'est à dire que au fur et
à mesure qu'il contient enfants tony on
ajoute une pièce est donc là été
construit dans les années 50 il est
complètement inadapté aujourd'hui aux
besoins de la communauté éducative
donc on doit absolument trouver une
solution et le département fait voter en
commission permanente a acté en
commission permanente
7 ce projet de faire suer les avirons un
nouveau collègue donc on remplit en
remplacement de celui ci il sera mieux
centraliser et répondent surtout aux
besoins de toute la communauté éducative
autre moment fort du déplacement aux
avirons la signature de la convention un
million d'arbres qui vise à planter 600
arbres endémiques et indigènes sur la
commune d'ici 2025
[Musique]